there are over 70 million middle
children in the United States right now
we're talking about over 70 million
Americans with both older and younger
siblings but if you watch a lot of
movies and television and I do you'd
think all middle children are exactly
the same
take for example Jan Brady of the Brady
Bunch
always angrily complaining about her
perfect system Marcia or malcolm in the
middle' whose parents always forget to
pick him up from school ron weasley lost
in a sea of red haired siblings drowning
in oversized hand-me-downs or sniffily
Edith from Downton Abbey
oh he's angry coveting everything her
sisters achieve again and again middle
children are depicted as neglected
ignored low in self-esteem starving for
attention and this has to come from some
basis in reality
after all our country's most famous
middle child right now would have to be
Kim Kardashian and who's more starving
for attention than her but I'm the
middle child and both my parents are
middle children so I've always been
fascinated at where this perception
middle children comes from society hands
us this view of birth order this
spectrum you have dominant eldest
children on one end and beloved youngest
children on the other us middle children
are just lost somewhere in between but
the more I've thought about it the more
wrong I've realised that world view is
today we'll start off by looking at
birth order research to understand where
this perception of middle children comes
from then we'll separately analyze the
role of older sibling and younger
sibling before finally bringing it all
together
to try to define what it means to live
from the middle whether you have
siblings or not so let's start with the
data researchers have done a great job
explaining characteristics of
first-borns and latter-borns
so who here is the oldest child in their
family a firstborn Wow
so you guys haven't made you will you'll
earn 1% more income than your younger
siblings and have fewer illnesses - over
60% of CEOs
hi V Lee graduates and US presidents are
first born in their family and as if
this wasn't all enough statistically
speaking your parents take way more
photos of you than your younger siblings
so you got a great head start in the
Instagram game now who here is the
youngest child in their family the baby
you guys have it pretty good - I'd say
you got more lenient punishments for the
same behavior compared to your siblings
you are more likely to protest for
positive social change and you have the
highest self-esteem of any birth order
so congratulations
although apparently you guys do not need
the ego boost so where does that leave
us middles a study out of Cornell talked
to mothers and found that regardless of
how many children they have mothers tend
to turn to their firstborn child in
moments of crisis when they need advice
but they feel the most emotionally
connected to their youngest child middle
children just didn't factor in heavily
to their answer to either question
professor Catherine salmon ran a similar
series of studies in one she asked
undergraduates who of all people you
know are you closest to what one person
64% of firstborn children and 39% of
last-born children named a parent as
that one person only 10% of middle
children did middle children have a
fundamentally different attachment style
to their parents and it's led
researchers to coin the term middle
child syndrome which refers to the
tendency of middle children to struggle
to find a role for themselves in their
family and as a result a role for
themselves in the world middle children
have the lowest self-esteem of any birth
order although I'd imagine having a
syndrome named after us isn't helping
things
so why do I want to speak out on behalf
of middle children because I think part
of the reason middle child syndrome
exists is because it's not something we
talk about or think about not part of
any conversation I've had discussions
with about a dozen middle children in
the last few weeks and I've been struck
by how difficult it is for us to define
our role in our family and how it shaped
us even though we know it did it comes
back to this fundamental question what
does it mean to live from the middle and
I think to understand that we first need
to understand separately the role of
older sibling and younger sibling
because they're very very different so I
grew up looking up to my older brother
Josh he's two years older than me and a
classic firstborn he's ambitious he's
driven he's high achieving responsible a
bit neurotic as a shortcut for my own
decision-making process I used to just
copy the things he did but trying to be
not to jam Brady about it I try to
define myself by doing the same things
as him but with my own spin differently
hopefully better if he played tennis I
play tennis if he did high school
newspaper I did too sometimes we even
dressed the same having an older sibling
gives you something to prove someone to
emulate but differentiate from on the
other hand being an older brother to
Bret who's three years younger give me
someone to approve someone to mentor
like many youngest children Bret is
artistic and creative he's an aspiring
graphic designer
my mom would often want me to spend more
time with Bret growing up so I play
video games with him never letting him
win of course I teach him how to use a
computer program or help him with his
math homework sometimes pretending to be
annoyed but always so happy that someone
needed my help and was willing to take
it so I think of my relationship with
Josh my relationship with Brett and how
different they are
and I think of this spectrum this
worldview were given about birth order
ambitious Josh on one end creative Brett
on the other me supposedly lost
somewhere in between
but that wasn't my experience as a
middle child being a middle child isn't
about being lost between two roles
it's about being firmly planted on both
ends of the spectrum at the same time to
have experience being older and younger
to know what it feels like to be the top
dog and the underdog and when you think
about that perception of being a middle
child it unlocks amazing and unique
qualities middle children from a young
age understand note that what it feels
like to be in a role of authority and a
role of inferiority and because of that
research has shown that middle children
are great negotiators great mediators
great peacekeepers they're comfortable
with ambiguity
similarly middle children don't have the
responsibility of the firstborn or the
attention of the last-born so they're
free to chart their own path they
measure high in measures of Independence
an NYU study compared middle born CEOs
the firstborn CEOs and found that middle
born CEOs tend to be change makers
they're used to setting their own
expectations so they're not afraid to do
things differently to experiment this
may explain Kim Kardashian's unique
approach to business so you you may be
thinking kind of these are qualities we
all can relate to and I think you're
right there are only 70 million middle
children in the United States but
there's 300 million of us who are used
to living from the middle because that's
what we're all doing at business schools
were taught to value traits that come
naturally to firstborns to want to be
the head of the pack to report to no one
to give a view from the top but life is
in business school we're not either
first years who have endless questions
or second years who know everything
we're somewhere in between were between
our board and our employees between our
managers and our reports we can be
between our family and our career or our
ego and our insecurities instead of
aspiring to make power plays or step on
anyone who gets in our way we can aspire
to take root firmly in the middle
because being a middle means having the
humility to take advice from others but
the confidence to know you have a voice
that you have worth a few years ago my
dad underwent an extensive brain surgery
it was the scariest day of my life but
in his road to full recovery it brought
my family closer together this picture
was taken a few months later my dad had
spent a few nights in the hospital
afterwards and preferred to not spend
them alone so I volunteered to camp out
in the chair next to his bed
napping chatting watching TV he asked
for help getting up out of bed and then
a few minutes later give me advice
remind me to take care of my mom the
next few weeks because it'd be tough on
her I would interrogate a doctor on his
behalf only an hour after after having
my dad proofread an email for me that I
might write my boss the nights were
filled with these moments where our
parent-child relationship was completely
inverted yet somehow it felt exactly the
same each of us sometimes acting older
sometimes acting younger but always
feeling comfortable in either role I
think those nights I Mass General
Hospital with my dad at 4:00 a.m. were
two middle children at their best
looking up and looking down at the very
same time and it's moments like these
that make me realize the view from the
middle it's not so bad thank you
you